[Music]
my name is amina omar
i'm 21 years old and i'm from london i
also have a youtube channel
where i just vlog hey i'm emmy i work at
buzzfeed japan as a designer i currently
live in tokyo
for about 20 years now like i don't
consciously think about why eat i do
know i snack a lot hopefully this week i
get to show you guys
what a 20 something year old eats during
the week
let's go let's start
[Music]
usually i have work today but my family
and i are going to some
japanese hot springs the cigarettes are
so loud but before we do that
i am going to our local bakery and
getting us
some bread so i'm eating kalepang
bread stuffed with curry um we're at the
park
i don't know if you can see the park
there's an ice cream around everyone
every corner having a big family picnic
for lunch and we have a bunch of food
here we have
fajitas burritos fruit
crisps chocolate just a bunch of things
this is my lunch it's a bento buckle
just like a variety of things is it
normal to have dinner at 10 p.m i don't
actually know but it's rice
with a little salad and some cold water
because it's like 30 degrees in london
right now
it's pretty common when you go to a
resort with hot springs to have
this elaborate meal for dinner pretty
much
a 10 course meal but miniature sized
for our main dish we had shabu-shabu
where you
have raw meat and swoosh it around in
hot broth until
it's cooked
[Music]
we were served this elaborate
traditional
japanese breakfast we have some fish
rice
egg custard and some warm tofu
i didn't have breakfast this morning so
for lunch it's
fish burger chips so basically in the uk
this specific fast food chain restaurant
isn't halal so i have to get a fish
burger uploading a video
and eating marshmallows mixed with
caramel
and then white chocolates
[Music]
but it's just so good so i've decided
that i need to stop being unhealthy and
i've got water grapes and i'm just penny
boarding
oh i'm back in my apartment just
snacking
on these they have like little cute
koala
prints on them my dinner is a wrap and
salad
and juice i tried to be slightly healthy
cauliflower
potato and broccoli this does not look
appetizing
at all tonight i am making um a type of
spaghetti dish that's called
naporita and it's basically
tomato sauce onion
green pepper bacon or sausage
simple spaghetti dish for a
quiet evening
[Music]
for breakfast just a bowl of rice
with natto which is fermented
soy beans sounds gross but
it is delicious just had breakfast
it just beans on toast with chocolate
milk i don't think it's normal to have
chocolate milk with everything i just
don't drink tea
beans on toast british stereotype very
true
tea with everything british stereotype
very true
i'm going to be making goya
this vegetable with tofu
eggs and some bacon
the pink walls are kind of a vibe
welcome to my crib
having a burger with chips she's got
poached eggs
she's got french toast
[Music]
today's dinner is which
literally translates to meat potatoes
all right itadakimasu for dinner we just
had roast chicken
in the uk there's this thing called
roast dinner we didn't have it but like
it's just a thing to have chicken
on sundays we just had it with chips yes
it's the second time i'm having chips
today
and now i'm just having an ice cream
because
dessert i'm eating this right now
i was grocery shopping and on my way
back i saw this store that was selling
dango and daifuku and like other
japanese sweets
it's really good
[Music]
so it is seven o'clock i'm just
eating cereal nothing special
[Music]
most big supermarkets you can go in
you can get a drink crisp or a snack and
a sandwich or a pasta pot
for three pounds so that's what i'm
getting for lunch
okay so i just finished my morning
meetings
i was thinking about takoyaki the whole
time so
i'm just gonna go and buy some because
that's what i'm craving
[Music]
i've got a chocolate chip no it's not
it's a cookie dough
sundae with fudge pieces what have you
got
belgian ruffled chocolate chip with hot
pudge
and almond sprinkles okay monday night
dinner
kept it pretty simple this is called
sanshokudong
oh i use meat beans and egg and
underneath
is some rice i'm just accompanying it
with some miso soup
and green tea okay so today's dinner is
just water and pasta with potatoes
lamb meat and coleslaw
not so much of a breakfast i wasn't
super hungry yeah just some english
breakfast tea
breakfast is one toast with butter
because i'm not hungry
that is the right amount of toast just
saying any dogs than this
you know it's summer in japan when you
have to
shout over these loud cicadas
my lunch today bought this at the
convenience store
evie deep fried shrimp
with some rice it's gonna enjoy it with
these bugs
another day another meal deal of course
crisp orange juice a pasta put and a
chocolate bar
that is lunch
yes i've ordered myself some korean
fried chicken
[Music]
shiny
okay so basically throughout the uk
there's this thing called um
eat out to help out and it's a
government scheme
where basically restaurants are 50 off
like everything their food um for every
monday tuesday and wednesday for the
whole month
just to kickstart the economy because
corona really ruined the economy
yes i'm just waiting for my pizza that
was 50 off
[Music]
okay i've made the executive decision
to go out and buy ice cream
no regrets today i'm
just making a sample smoothie from
frozen mangoes for some pineapple
drinkable yogurt and orange juice i'm
literally going to be late for work if i
miss the busters in five minutes and i'm
eating a banana
i do have a meeting that starts in a
couple of minutes so i'm really gonna
rush
so i ran to the convenience store and
bought myself some rice balls
salmon red beans sour plum with
boiled kelp i'm gonna go to a different
what's good supermarket today and show
you guys mild deal there
lunch was a tuna sandwich crisps banana
and strawberry smoothie
tonight's dinner is another pasta dish
pasta which is spicy fish eggs
and seaweed on top for dinner we're
doing the
government's 50 off thing again we're
just making use of it
and we're going to a burger place i
think i'm going to get a normal beef
burger
50 50
for breakfast today i'm having a fruit
jelly cup pretty self-explanatory just
so we're clear
it's definitely called jelly not
jello what is jello
my boss is in eight minutes nine minutes
so i'm i'm having a banana if i'm early
i'll go and get some pastry
while you're in the video
i just got a pasta pot fruit
and a smoothie for lunch and my hair
scoff's falling off
we have shokayaki course i have to have
my rice
miso soup and burdock salad
i need this before it gets cold
[Music]
this is not healthy but i promise you my
dinner was healthy
so the week's over i hope it's not too
different to what other british people
eat
hope you enjoyed the video i know i did
because
i ate a lot of food i'm eating right now
it's melting
it was quite a typical week of food
thanks for watching
you